and Anish uh for the aim chess rapid we
have also gotten some very cool aim
chess
and I want to bring them up for you to
look at your aim chest stats this is
um head-to-head against Abdus but first
of all your average tentiple loss is
so good 18. what's your reaction to that
I can tell you so I mean where are the
handcuffs you can just take me to change
the hill right away exactly I can
explain that I'll explain that like you
know like Hans I'll explain I'll explain
like what I'll explain okay so the
accent that's because I'm half Russian
but anyway so jokes aside I can explain
you my Cindy ponos so the thing is as a
rule I play compared to many other
players a relatively simple chess simple
positions so the problem with that the
good thing with that is that it's very
easy for me to play them so I make very
little mistakes the problem with that is
that my opponents have the same so if
you analyze my opponent's Senti Pawn
loss
theirs will be also very low nobody will
do that of course but you should do that
as well now uh one of the interesting
thing is the highest centiped loss from
great players
is uh by shirov and Tau so players who
are playing sacrificing chess they were
losing lots of Center pawns themselves
but they were provoking their opponents
to lose antipodes as well so you have to
see not only yours and upon us but your
opponent's antipolos in fact Talent
should have had the highest opponents
antipolos so this is what's going on
here I have a at least so far mostly
played simple chess and that makes my um
yeah that that's why my chest plays for
it by itself for itself speaks for
itself yeah my opponents just speaks for
itself as well that's the problem